night at 8:00 Eastern and Pacific on
c-span QA
next historian Edward bonnet Kemper
discusses his book the myth of the lost
cause why the South fought the Civil War
and why the North won it examines
post-war arguments made by former
Confederates seeking to justify their
split from the Union and their defeat
mr. Bona kempert argues that slavery and
not states rights was the primary reason
for succession he also disputes several
other aspects of the lost cause myth
such as the idea that Confederate
General Robert E Lee was a better
commander than ulysses s grant and a
grant only defeated Lee because of
superior troop numbers and resources
this myth Sounion associates posted this
to our event good evening everyone can
everyone hear me well yes good I'm Mary
McLaughlin and I'm a program coordinator
with the Smithsonian associates and I'd
like to welcome all of you tonight to
what promises to be a very stimulating
program on the myth of the lost cause it
is always a pleasure to welcome ed Bona
Kemper back to the Smithsonian through
the years he has presented many
outstanding programs for us on Civil War
topics in fact this is his tenth
appearance with the Smithsonian
associates Edie is the book review
editor of Civil War news which reviews
all 250 plus new Civil War books each
year he was an adjunct lecturer in
military history at Muhlenberg College
for 8 years and has history degrees from
Muhlenberg and from Old Dominion
University as well as a law degree from
Yale he served as a lawyer with the
federal government for more than 34
years and as a retired commander in the
US Coast Guard Reserve he is the author
of six books on Civil War history
including the myth of the lost cause why
the South fought the Civil War and why
the North won which was published last
fall and on which tonight's program is
based and his book will be available
through Smithsonian Museum shops of the
outside the entrance to this auditorium
at the end of tonight's program and EDD
will be happy to sign copies for you
then so with that said we have a very
packed two hours in store for you I know
this is going to be a very engaging
program so we want to bring it up please
join me in giving a very warm welcome to
s-bahn members
Thank You Mary it's a pleasure being
back here at the Smithsonian to talk
about the Civil War and I really
appreciate the great turnout tonight it
certainly shows the lengths to which
people will go to avoid presidential
town halls and and also I do have to to
confess that as you heard I've got to
history degrees and a law degree so you
will be hearing an argumentative
historian this evening which is probably
a good time for me to say that these are
my personal comments are based on my
personal research they do not
necessarily reflect the views of the
Smithsonian at all this is completely
Bono Kemper bono Kemper talking to you
so Mary and the Smithsonian should be
off the hook
okay we're here tonight to discuss a
very important topic and that is the
myth of the lost cause now I'll give you
a couple examples of of the myth of the
myth in action and and then and then go
on explain what the details are of the
myth what the components are of the myth
and also then we'll take a look at each
one the myth of the Lost Cause was
created by ex-confederates mediocre
General Jubal Early totally incompetent
General William Nelson Pendleton and
Reverend William Jones between 1860 and
1900
to basically justify the Civil War what
had happened was of the North fought the
war the north
on the war northerners went back home
and resumed their daily lives and really
didn't care much about writing about the
war until maybe a hundred years after
the war southerners on the other hand
had a lot to write about they had a lot
to justify what had happened was the
almost the entire war was fought in the
south and the South was just an economic
basket case by the end of the war
because Northern armies had gone through
and destroyed pretty much anything of
economic value in addition you have to
realize that the south major institution
social institution that is slavery had
suddenly come to an end and there were
between three and a half and four
million slaves with big questions about
what happens to these african-americans
and so southerners felt compelled to
explain why it was that this devastation
had occurred and that for example 25
percent of southern white men between
the ages of 20 and 45 were dead not just
casualties they were dead as a result of
the Civil War so it was a lot explained
of explaining to do and that's the the
origin of the myth of those first 30
years but it has continued and probably
the best example of the seven volumes by
Douglas Southall Freeman in the 1930s
and 1940s of first of all explaining in
in the first four volumes called Archie
Lee that Lee walked on water and then in
the next three volumes basically
explaining any thoughts that Lee - might
appear to have had by blaming all his
subordinates
that's called Lee's lieutenants which
could have been called Lee's scapegoats
and that was the continuation of the
myth of lost cause the reason I felt
compelled to write the book was as I
went around the country talking to
members of civil war round tables I
found that a lot of people who in my
view should have known better were
greatly affected
and bought into a very many aspects of
the myth of a lost cause so that's why I
think it's important for all of us to
consider what the myth is and how much
we want to buy into that myth a good
example of what I'm talking about sort
of a little change of position that
occurred among southern leaders was on
the threshold of the Civil War as seven
southern states were succeeding before
Lincoln even took office
Jefferson Davis a senator from
Mississippi gave a very emotional
farewell address to the United States
Senate in which he said sayanora
and in that address he explained that he
felt compelled to leave and that his
state felt compelled to leave the Union
because the institution of slavery was
being threatened by the federal
government and by northern states and so
that was his discussion in 1860 61
believe that was December 1862 decades
later in 1881
Jefferson Davis published his - volume
of memoirs and in those in that work
Jefferson Davis adopts the traditional
myth of the Lost Cause position and says
well slavery really had almost nothing
to do with the war in fact he states
specifically there would have been a
civil war even if no American had owned
a slave okay you just I won't comment on
which one I think is truth or the
fiction but just note the contrast
between the two and this is very typical
and it's why it is so important to go
back and look at the evidence at the
time of secession and the time of the
formation of the Confederacy now as I
said a lot of people have bought into
this over the years and I think it
greatly affected the historiography of
the Civil War whether you were born
north south east or west you
or some or all of the of the myth and
that's why it's important to understand
what the myth is and do and to examine
how our you think it is based upon the
evidence now the statement I have behind
me and I'll try to not rely upon the
lower left corner because I realized at
least a quarters you can't see it anyway
this is a quote from John Keegan
now John Keegan is or was an
internationally recognized military
historian wrote about 20 military
history books and so he he lived in
England he to be honest he did not
understand the civil war that well he
wrote a book on it eventually and it was
not a very good book but in one of his
other books on intelligence in war he
just made a general statement sort of
off the cuff and this is where
historians run into trouble
and and I do I do myself all the time
you try to make a general statement
about something which is tangential to
what you're really writing about and
what you really know about and Keegan
said the southern people were resolute
in their determination to preserve
states rights the legal issue over which
they had declared separation so he
bought into what I consider to be the
myth that states rights was what the
secession and the formation of the
Confederacy were all about
so let's now springboard off of that and
let me tell you what I see as the major
components of the myth the first one
I've just stated and I think that's an
absolutely critical one slavery slavery
was not the primary cause states rights
with the primary cause of the of the
Civil War that's I'm now talking on the
left there the the myth goes on that
slavery was a benign institution
beneficial to whites and blacks light
but then all of a sudden that jumps into
the myth jumps into
something that sounds a little
inconsistent with what I've just said
and it says by the way the Civil War was
unnecessary because slavery was going to
expire on its own within a fairly
reasonable period of time and we'll take
a look we'll take a look at that further
the argument goes the South never had a
chance to win the war and one would ask
well if that's so then why did you start
the work and thus the South did the best
that could with the resources that it
had and part of this then is that robert
e lee was the great military leader and
that he was one of the greatest generals
who ever lived and you will find a lot
of the books that take the lost cause
position they talk about lead literally
in christ-like terms
talking about Golgotha and Gethsemane
and blessing the children etc etc it
truly is a mini god of the myth of a
lost cause now there were a couple
problems with that one is that he
currently lost a really big battle at
Gettysburg so what to do about that well
that became fairly easy to deal with
James Longstreet was made the scapegoat
for Lee's losing Gettysburg and one
reason for that is because he he had to
go along she had the gall to actually
take a position in the grant
administration as a collector of tariffs
in the in New Orleans so he he went over
to the Republican side and that was just
a death to a political career in the
south and made him a sitting target to
become the scapegoat of Gettysburg
now also of course Lee ultimately
surrendered to grant and so you had an
issue of it least so great
why they lose to grant so that that myth
goes of that grant of one only by being
a butcher a grant was a butcher and that
he only wand by brute force and finally
sort of the newest spin on the myth of
the lost cause is that
Union forces only won by engaging in
total war total war that's a phrase
that's really I think being bandied
about fairly loosely these days and we
will we will take a brief look at that
okay we will start out with what was the
nature of slavery in 1861 up I don't
really think we need to do deal very
long with the issue of what slavery
beneficial to whites and blacks
certainly certain White's benefited from
it and keep in mind please
when I say slavery tonight in shorthand
I will be referring to slavery slash
white supremacy and one reason I do that
is because if you and South and even if
you did not personally or somebody in
your family - not personally owned a
slave you are still the social
beneficiary of the existence of slavery
and that can simply be explained by
saying that no matter how poor a Dirt
Farmer you were and how little you owned
you always knew that in your society
there were four million people who were
inferior to you as a matter of law and
of social practice so that said let's
look at slavery itself and the reason I
said we don't need to spend much time is
basically we have a long history of
rapes and murders of slaves we have we
have the beatings we have the scars on
the back we have massive movements of
slaves from the northern tier of
southern states from Maryland and
Virginia primarily down to the deep
south the best estimate is that about 1
million slaves were sold out of the
northern south at the border states or
the north or the the northern southern
states into the deep south about 1
million slaves and if you take that
million and and adjust and then actually
increase for the number of transactions
that didn't
involved such long-distance transfers I
think it is a fair estimate and probably
about a million slaves over the 200 plus
years of slavery were separated from
their families there was children taken
from parents wives taken from husbands
etc there was no thought really given to
trying to keep the families together
except in rare instances all I'm saying
is a very common practice to split the
families I put that in quotes because
you have to keep in mind that part of
the devastating effect of slavery was
that slave marriages were not recognized
slaves had first names that didn't have
last names again marriage not recognized
and children were the property of the
mother's owner and as far as far as the
owner was concerned it was his economic
decision as to what to do with those
slaves whether the hold em whether to
sell them etc so there was a devastating
impact on the african-american family
because they were really legally kept
from forming family groups as as we know
them okay I don't think I need to say
too much more about justifying slavery
except just to remind you that one
reason this comes up is because of
approaches to the to the south the I'll
call the mint julep approach as
reflected in the movie and the novel
Gone with the Wind
so just take a look at things with a
with a big shaker for salt okay now as I
said there was something that seems to
me a little bit inconsistent in them in
the myth which is that despite this
wonderful benevolent institution it was
going to come to an end within a
reasonable period of time will say
defined loosely maybe as before 1900
because it was no longer really
beneficial economically to the owners
and
and and the reason this argument is made
is because then it can be argued the
civil war was unnecessary civil war was
unnecessary
northerners didn't have to fight the war
because slavery was going to disappear
anyway if you look at the records you
will see that the value of slaves
throughout the states that became the
Confederacy were on the rise in 1860
they had reached the highest point
they'd ever reached cotton sales were
way up the value of cotton had continued
to increase but also keep in mind that
slaves were not only used to raise
cotton slaves were used for tobacco for
rice indigo they they were used for a
lot of crops a lot of foreign production
but also by this time a lot of owners
had recognized that you know some slaves
to put despite the fact that they were
put down as a group some slaves had real
talents as artisans blacksmiths
carpenters etc so they were being they
were being left out and in addition as
the South was starting to get
industrialized very early stages slaves
were being used in industrial arenas so
for example in Richmond Virginia the
tobacco plants are you talking about
creating creating cigars or syrettes
slaves were almost the exclusive labor
to run all the tobacco factories even
more interesting again in Richmond you
had the Tredegar Iron Works which was a
key industrial force in the Civil War
making first we call the Confederate
artillery armory they were the the Iron
Works for the Confederacy was to
Tredegar Iron Works and I was almost
exclusively manned by black slaves so
there the southerners were beginning to
figure out from an economic perspective
board there are a lot of other uses to
which we can put slaves how part of the
argument that slavery was going to go
away is also that the South had run out
of Lane
that could be developed for agriculture
I think the simple rebuttal to that is
that between 1865 and 1925 the amount of
land dedicated to agriculture in the
south triple it tripled so the more
recent studies really show that the land
was there to be developed for
agriculture it's just that economically
it wasn't being done at the time also in
terms of slavery disappearing the
estimate of the southerners themselves
in their secession resolutions was that
they were defending an institution which
had assets in slaves of four to six
billion dollars that was in the dollars
of those days that would be hundreds of
billions of dollars now in fact if you
categorized assets in the United States
that was the biggest single category of
the most valuable single category of
assets in the United States was the
value of slaves so I personally see no
indication that slavery was about to to
go away now now we get to the $64,000
question and that is what caused
secession and what caused the formation
of the Confederacy now I say that once
you had a number of states seceding like
starting with seven events were going to
eleven but we'll start with the 7/7 Deep
South states seceded between Lincoln's
election in November 1860 and his
inauguration in March of 1861 the Seven
Deep South states seceded and they
immediately began seizing all the Union
forts armories etc weapons scattered
throughout the south the only ones that
escaped seizure were for Dickens for
Dickens at Pensacola and Fort Sumter at
Charleston other than that South was
already seizing these weapons
they were actually the states were
buying weapons in Europe they were
preparing for war and ultimately a
deliberate decision was made personally
by Jefferson Davis authorizing PGT
Beauregard to bombard Fort Sumter to
start the war and given the reasons for
the South Sea seeding and forming the
Confederacy it should not be a surprise
that once those things were in place
there was it was going to be a war and
as we'll see there were a lot of people
who were trying to avoid a war by
dealing with the issue of slavery okay
the first thing I want to do is look at
contemporary evidence 1860 1861 I think
that's the only or the most valid way to
determine the cause of secession and the
formation of the Confederacy which is
relevant today lot of people display or
wave the Confederate battle flag and my
question is basically when they're doing
that what what does that flag stand for
seems to me that's the Confederate flag
stands for the Confederacy what did the
Confederacy stand for and we as a
society ought to look into that issue
and draw our own conclusions about why
why the Confederacy why the Confederacy
now to me anything that occurred
anything that is said after about the
middle of 1864 when it was pretty clear
the South was going down the tubes
anything from that date to the present
is second-guessing it's looking back and
it's imposing one's own personal views
on on the situation god forbid that I
would want to impose any of my personal
views on any of this but my point is
that I'm trying to focus on what
actually happened in 1860 and 61 and
look at that contemporaneous evidence I
think that is our
thousand evidence of why there was a
confederacy I think you have you have a
handout which has which has this on it
okay V there just there a couple couple
points I want to make from these
statistics which I put together from a
couple of different sources the first
thing is that only slave states seceded
from the Union they're about sixteen
three states fifteen slave states the
only states that ever succeeded for all
slave states that might tell you
something that there was more than just
states rights at issue now among the
group of slave states among the fifteen
there are three categories the first
category are the early C seizures of the
seven states that went out before
Lincoln even was president and then you
have four more who went out after fort
sumter did not want to take up arms
against their their fellow southern
states and had a great deal of interest
in preserving slavery as well and then
you had four other slave states
specifically Delaware Maryland Kentucky
and Missouri which are known as the
border states those slave states never
succeeded so let's look at this data and
see if there's a correlation between
what I'll just summarize initially has
the blackness of a state and how likely
it was to see seed and when it was
likely to see seed so the big numbers up
here are in books in the in the first
group in the first group of of seven
that went out early the 47% of the
population was slaves
47% of the total population was slaves
and and here's the number that may shop
some of you 37 percent of the families
in those states owned slaves
now I say it may shock you because the
promulgate errs of the lost cause like
to say things like did you know that
only
1% of Americans owned slaves in 1860
so slaves could not a slaver II could
not have been a cause of the war well
that of course includes everybody north
and south and man Wilma woman and
children so let's just focus on certain
states and then not look at individuals
because under that I well and let me let
me move on there's another there's
another related rationale which is that
you know that only about 5% of
southerners owned slaves five percent of
Southerners owned slaves
so therefore the worker not have been
about slavery but what that does is it
says if you love a family and you have a
father who loans X number of slaves and
he's married to his wife and he's got
eight kids that's really ten people who
benefit from having one or more slaves
in the family and so I think it is
rational to look at how many families
directly owned slaves and this doesn't
even get us into what goes beyond that
which is the whole social structure and
how we'll call the lower class whites
cell about having 4 million people by
law subservient to them but let's look
at this now and and 37 percent of the
families in this ec in the first
seceding states owned slaves
now the second batch is who ones after
Fort Sumter we had a third 29% 29% of
the population was slaves and 25 percent
of the families owned slaves and then
finally in the four border states on the
upper right here the last ones on your
handout only 14% of the population
consisted of slaves and only 16 percent
of the families owned slaves so just on
a demographic basis it appears to me
that there is a significant relationship
between slave population and family
ownership of slaves
and the willingness to leave the Union
and the earlier the better in cases
where the those numbers were higher okay
enough about that
the best evidence the best evidence of
why there was a confederacy is as you
would expect in the words of the c
cedars themselves in the words of the c
cedars themselves and and and that is
mind-boggling because you can study the
documents that were issued by the states
about why they seceded and you don't
find mention of the word terrible which
is a red herring that's often thrown out
there and actually you don't see states
rights either what you see is a long
list of slavery related issues now the
let's see if I've got some of these here
I think okay we're going to look just
take a look at two of them
let me first back off and say that of
the seventh first seceding states six of
them left clear statements about why
they were succeeding actual documents in
their secession resolutions or companion
documents saying here's why we did this
and only louisiana was silent but we
have other ways of looking at louisiana
as well but we're right now just
exploring here's what people said about
why they were succeeding why they were
forming a confederacy first of all the
first one out of course south carolina
and so they issued a declaration of
immediate causes for seceding from the
union and their complaints were northern
states and federal government failure to
return fugitive slaves in accordance
with the Constitution and federal law
quote but in increasing hostility on the
part of the non-slaveholding States to
the institution of slavery has led to
the to a disregard of their obligations
and
the general government has ceased to
affect the objects of the Constitution
South Carolina complain northern states
had condemned slavery as sinful
northerners had elected as president a
man who had said government cannot
endure permanently half slave half free
they even criticized the fact that some
northern states had the audacity to
allow free blacks to vote
so my conclusion in South China is far
from respecting other states rights to
do past liberty laws for example or
extend certain freedoms or rights to
african americans they-they-they
South Carolinians were opposed to these
states being able to choose themselves
what they would do or not do but in
addition we have them complaining that
the federal government is not doing
enough the federal government is not in
their view aggressively enforcing the
the Fugitive Slave provisions of the
Constitution and the federal law now you
should be aware that believe it or not
the US Constitution as originally
adopted had a specific provision that
required runaway slaves to be returned
back to the states from which they had
played this is not just a matter of
federal law and then about 1792 Congress
put that in law and as you well know in
1850 that statute was strengthened quite
a bit but this is typical the southern
complaint and fugitive slavery is a big
big source of aggravation and complaint
by the southern states is a complaint
that the federal government is not doing
enough doesn't sound like they're really
concerned primarily with states rights
visa be the federal government they want
the federal government to do what they
want the federal government to do which
is to preserve slavery now Mississippi
was right in there behind South Carolina
and their governor urged the convening
of a secession convention and he said
the existence or the abolition of
African slavery in the southern states
is now up for a final settlement the
legislature called for AC session
convention and they had a long list of
grievances so there's now the
Mississippi legislature convening a
secession convention they complained
that the North had defied the
Constitution's Fugitive Slave provision
interfered with slavery enticed slaves
to free aggitated against slavery sought
to exclude slavery from the territories
and opposed the admission of more slave
states
moreover abolitionists sought to amend
the Constitution to prohibit slavery and
the punish slaveholders they had
encouraged John Brown's raid and had
elected an president and vice president
who were hostile to the south and its
system of labor and so the legislature
left no doubt why they were convening a
secession convention and the convention
basically used the same kind of language
and and obviously succeeded very quickly
the convention said in their declaration
of the causes of secession they said
this our position is thoroughly
identified with the institution of
slavery the greatest material interest
of the world its labor supplies the
product which constitutes by far the
largest and most important portions of
Commerce of the earth these products are
peculiar to the climate verging on the
tropical regions and by an imperious law
of nature none but the black race can
bear exposure to the tropical Sun these
products have become necessities of the
world and they blow it slavery as a blow
at civilization and commerce that blow
has long been aimed at the institution
and was at the point of reaching its
consummation there was no choice
left to us but submission to the
mandates of abolition or a dissolution
of the Union whose principles had been
subverted to work out our ruin now
that's not some summary by me that's
verbatim what the Mississippi secession
convention said and they had a long list
of grievances they got into then 16
slavery related grievances which brings
us around to the point being in all this
I just want to give you a couple
examples the point being in all these
documents in which the states explained
why they were succeeding and why they
were forming a confederacy one word that
runs through it all and the word is
slavery slavery slavery slavery slavery
and and really no other reasons given
and most of these documents are readily
available you can google them you can
find them in the official records of the
Civil War a Civil War encyclopedia
called Heidler and Heidler so these are
around if you want to just check up on
the be my guess because I think reading
these things will be an eye-opening
experience
okay now simultaneous with the whiskey
session you had other things that were
occurring which tells us a lot about why
there was secession
first of all there were settlement
efforts being made to try to avoid war I
mean the country was not stupid the
whole election of 1860 the 4way
presidential election in which Lincoln
emerged the winner was all that one
issue and that issue was extension of
slavery into the territories or not with
the candidates having different
positions on that issue but it was that
issue which people were voting on almost
exclusively that was that was the issue
and so when Lincoln comes in gets
elected on the basis of no slavery into
the territories that sets off fire bells
in the south and they are very very
concerned
about that issue as I said people were
not done and and there was a great view
ization that all this could lead to war
and so there were certain leaders in the
federal government and in some of the
states who want to try to avoid war and
so if we take a little look at what
kinds of compromises they wanted to work
out to avoid war we get some real good
contemporaneous insight into what was
what was in people's minds what was
thought to be the cause of secession and
if we could deal with certain issues how
could we avoid a civil war well the
first major development was in December
of 1860 and January of 1861 when the
Senate in the house put together a
massive committee 33 members one from
each state and and they came up with
proposed constitutional amendments now
these are generally called the
Crittenden amendments after John
Crittenden of Kentucky who was the
leader in this compromise effort
obviously he comes from a slavery state
but that state actually never did see
seed so Crittenden was making a
good-faith effort to try to avoid war as
were most of the other people who put
this package together but the key folk
the key point is what was the focus of
the package what were what were the
compromises what were the constitutional
amendments that were recommended in the
same months when South Carolina seceded
and then other states started to follow
suit well here here are what the
Crittenden amendments would have done to
the Constitution extend the Missouri
Compromise
slave free line to the Pacific Ocean
recognize and protect slavery in
existing slave states and all present
and future territories and then prohibit
Congress
I'm interfering with the interstate
trade from abolishing slavery in DC
unless certain conditions were met
freeing the slaves of federal officials
brought to BC that's when congressman
showed up with their own slaves they
didn't want them to become free by
virtue of showing up in the district
prohibiting or interfering and
interstate transport of slaves these are
all things that Congress would be
prohibited by the Constitution from from
doing and then here is the beauty here
is my favorite is Congress would be
prohibited from passing any future
constitutional amendments allowing any
of the above or authorizing
congressional interference with or
abolishment of slavery okay so in other
words we not only are going to address
this variety of slave issues all in
accordance with the wishes of the
succeeding states but we were also going
to say in the Constitution and by the
way this can never be changed this can
never be changed now for our purposes
that the point again is that every one
of these points dealt with slavery
they're all addressing slavery issue
there's nothing in here about tariffs
and there's nothing in here about states
rights it is
about slavery then and by the way this
the Crittenden amendments went nowhere
they were considered in Congress Lincoln
sent word to the Republican leadership
which now controlled the Congress
especially since Southern Democrats were
bailing out which made it easier Lincoln
sent the word to Republican party
leaders that they were not to go along
with any amendments along these lines
because doing so would be totally
inconsistent with why the Republican
Party was formed in 1854 with the
principles Republican Party stood for
and with the election results of 1860
when the plurality of Americans voted
not to extend slavery into the
territories by
supporting the Republicans so Lincoln's
herself this would be a total sellout of
everything that he and his party stood
for so he passed the word no and so that
that guaranteed that these amendments
were going nowhere but again for our
purposes the important thing to note is
that major effort made to avoid war by
addressing what issues slavery issues
okay continuing that trend the next
month in February of 1862 or 1861 there
was a major peace conference in
Washington DC and fortuitously there's a
brand new book out on that called the
peace that almost was the peace that
almost was by mark two weeks t oo le Y
and it's an excellent book
I think there's a disconnect between the
publishers title and the contents of the
book which I have experienced myself but
but the because I think the title is
overly optimistic the peace that almost
was because it wasn't going to happen it
wasn't going to happen and what happened
is that seven states were already out so
the remaining slave states the four 4x8
southern states that had not succeeded
pretty much came L came and most of the
northern states came to this month-long
conference in Washington DC and at that
conference lo and behold what did they
do they develop proposed constitutional
amendments to avoid war that was what
they were all about so what did this set
of constitutional amendments say it said
reinstate the Missouri Compromise
boundaries between sleep free and free
and slave territories require a majority
of slave state senators to approve new
terror
prohibit Congress from interfering with
existing slavery affirming the Fugitive
Slave laws ban the importation of slaves
and require unanimous approval as my
favorite on this collection require
unanimous approval by the states to
revoke any of these constitutional
amendments in other words these are
going to be locked in forever as well so
obviously one month after the Crittenden
amendments were shot down the peace
conference recommendations for also
going nowhere at all in fact it's kind
of ironic ex-president John Tyler of
Virginia which had not yet succeeded
chaired chaired the conference
ex-president big name and so he was a
big pusher to try to get pro-slavery
constitutional amendments as part of
their agenda he got what he wanted he
stated on the final day of the
conference that it was now his
obligation to present these to Congress
to try to see about getting them passed
so he basically sent them pro forma to
the Senate never sent them to the House
and the next day he showed up in
Richmond as a member of the Virginia
secession convention and and and it
happened attacked all the proposals as
we as ridiculous so but again that's all
very interesting but again the point is
trying to avoid war this group came up
with and these are political leaders now
from the state's not not from Congress
political leaders from the states came
up with their proposals and they were
virtually identical to the Crittenden
ones and what they shared in common was
that they all dealt with slavery we now
also can take a look at southern leaders
statements early in the war or even the
before the war as to what this was all
about as I said before Davis had
his statement in his farewell address to
to Congress when he when he went home
and his vice president Alexander
Stephens of Georgia gave us a real
helping hand in trying to understand
what was going on he delivered in
Savannah Georgia in about February of
1861 an address which is called the
cornerstone address and it's called the
cornerstone address because in his talk
Stephen said the cornerstone of the
Confederacy is slavery the cornerstone
of the Confederacy of slavery now quite
frankly I had known not from general
reading before but when I pulled this
entire speech out and read it through
and it's widely available to I was
astounded to the extent that Steven's
went in the detail and what he did was
he said you know the founding fathers
Thomas Jefferson and those other guys
made a very serious mistake because they
said that all men are created equal
well we know that in the Confederacy
Confederate stands for the principle
that all white men are created equal
and black men are here to serve us and
it was very specific about this now
immediately after the Civil War he
started the usual backing down and his
back down excuse was that he was
misquoted
this Islam is one of the longest miss
quotes in world history and the problem
for him is that not only did the
Savannah paper carry the story about
this speech in Savannah the Atlanta
papers carried the same story about a
speech he gave in Atlanta in which he
made the same point so the Confederate
leaders contemporaneously with C session
and the formation of the Confederacy
told us what their views were at that
time and so now we've got Stevens
bailing out I told you before that that
Davis bailed out later and said there
would have been award even if nobody
owned any slaves at all so that's why I
say that if we're really looking at
why the Confederacy kind of go back to
the beginning and look at it
contemporaneously and forget about
everyone else's rationales later and I
don't care what side the rationale was
on just that's nice to know but it's
pretty much irrelevant let's go back to
primary original evidence okay the
Confederacy's Constitution adopted at
the same time I'm thinking very early
April 1861 of six states and then Texas
came in so actually that would they
would have started doing this in in
February and then they adopted a
preliminary one and then a final one
okay if you look at the Confederate
Constitution you would think that would
tell you something about why is there a
Confederacy and what what the
Confederate leaders did in the
Constitution was pretty much copy the US
Constitution except as expected they
built in a lot of extra protections for
slavery and pretty much said you
couldn't tamper with those down the road
but perhaps because I'm a lawyer I
focused on one provision in the
Confederate Constitution which I think
tells us a lot and that is that there's
a Supremacy Clause in the federal
council in the Confederate Constitution
very similar to the federal one to the
US Constitution Supremacy Clause says
the supreme law in the Confederacy is
this Constitution Confederate treaties
Confederate law and it says state judges
are bound by the that supreme law
regardless of what state law says hmm
okay it sounds to me like the southern
states had switched masters and and not
that each state was going to stand alone
and be its and be its own government but
they were they were basically looking
for a more compatible and understanding
of superior government and not doing
this purely on the principle of states
rights because that one cause basically
throws states rights out the window and
puts the puts the power in the
Confederacy just as the Supremacy Clause
of the US Constitution in general puts
the power in the United States
government when push comes to shove and
there's any conflict and there's any
conflict over the issues listen we are
here okay the rest of the rest of this
is already in your outline so I'm not
going to to worry about exactly what's
on the board any given time okay how
especially since a quarter you can't see
it anyway okay so sticking to sticking
to the outline the motivation of the
four leaders receiving states is again
pretty much documented as being slavery
related the leaders talked about it the
their secession conventions talked about
it and it's very almost like a replay of
the earlier seceding states but things
are now reached a crisis stage because
they were succeeding in time of warfare
and a lot of them simply did not they
did not want to take up arms against
their sister states and they wanted to
defend slavery in fact the four border
states almost went to and that was one
of Lincoln's big concerns throughout the
war okay I've given you a lot of
evidence contemporaneous with formation
of the Confederacy about what the
Confederacy was about now I want to go
beyond that and look at the Confederate
government's behavior during the Civil
War which would shed additional light on
their purpose and what i submit to you
as my personal view
is that the behavior of the Confederacy
in several key areas demonstrates that
Confederate leaders were more concerned
about preserving slavery than they were
unbelievably than in winning the war and
in winning the war and preserving your
independence that it was all about
slavery and so what are the kinds of
things I'm talking about well the first
is fairly controversial area the
rejection of using slaves as soldiers
now you might say wait a minute
wait a minute I've heard that there were
some slaves fighting for the south
I mean look just in 2010 of the
Commonwealth of Virginia well-known for
the accuracy of its school textbooks
published a book that said two thousand
blacks fought under the command of
Stonewall Jackson and so when challenged
on it the department person who had come
up with this addition to the text said
oh that was on the Internet
that's so I mean it sounds like a good
source kind of at least that it was
Wikipedia but it was only it was on the
internet so that was that was the source
of that and now I will be the first to
admit that there were probably several
thousand blacks who went with their
masters to war because the masters
weren't used to pressing their clothes
doing their laundry and all those
wonderful little things that slaves can
do and so a lot of officers in the
Confederacy took one slave with them to
the battlefield and there certainly
would have been instances where the
master gets killed or wounded and slave
picks up a gun and fires it or takes
care of the master gets the master home
or the masters body home and so there
would be an appearance of slave
participation and in addition there's no
doubt that tens of thousands of slaves
were used as slaves to build
fortifications and to
two mundane things which are part of
military life but which do not include
actually engaging in combat
now another another favorite example of
those who say that slaves participate or
blacks at least participated on behalf
of the Confederacy is the Louisiana
Guards
the Louisiana Guards that was a unit of
about 2,000 mixed-race people Louisiana
already was a great blending place
blending of the races and so there were
people there who were free and had mixed
blood so a lot of people would
characterize them as black even though
through a very mixed race and they
signed up at the beginning of the war
they said okay what we have a company is
called the Louisiana guards and and we
want to fight with our neighbors we want
to do whatever our neighbors want to do
this may very well have been to preserve
their status in society whatever we
don't know the reasons probably differed
from man to man but what's interesting
and so the argument goes well my god
here you had two thousand blocks lining
themselves up with the Confederacy but
what happened to them what happened to
them is they were not part of the
Confederate Army they were part of the
Louisiana militia they were never
provided with arms by either the federal
government or the state government and
that by early 1862 the Louisiana
Legislature figured out that this really
didn't look too good and so they changed
the law and said to be in the Louisiana
militia you must be all white so so I
think that example turns out to turn
back on itself and to demonstrate once
again that the South had a great deal
reluctance to use black soldiers now
let's get to what's really pretty clear
and that is that until five weeks before
automatics the Confederate government
never officially allowed the you
to slaves so that got tells us something
right there that this was an issue
raised periodically throughout the war
and that until March of 1865 it this
practice was not authorized even then it
had strings on it and so what that tells
us is 1861 1862 1863 1864 and more than
two months into 1865 the Confederate
Congress did not authorize slaves to be
used in the Confederate Army
and so it's hard to argue that that well
the Confederacy did this and thousands
fought for them etc when as a matter of
fact the law prohibited in the
Confederacy now further evidence of what
we're talking about here is that in on
Jan January the 2nd 1864 Patrick Claver
irish-born which might have had
something to do with it didn't maybe buy
into all the social mores of the south
Patrick Cleburne
one of the best maybe the best
Confederate generals saw what was going
on concerning manpower the Confederacy
started the war outnumbered three and a
half to one and white men of of oint men
of fighting age three and a half to one
they were they were outnumbered and so
they had a desperate need for manpower
and despite that they had not moved
forward using their slaves well by the
end of 1863 this is following Gettysburg
and Chickamauga Chattanooga and many
other blood baths the Confederacy was
really down to the bottom they were now
not on recruiting but drafting boys and
men from age 15 to 45 and still didn't
have enough manpower so Clayburn frankly
spoke up and he produced an issue paper
a well thought out issue paper on the
subject in which he said
president Davis has done all he could to
drum up a voluntarily or involuntarily
support from the whites all over the
south we've gone out and dragged people
kicking and screaming out of the
Appalachian to fight for the Confederacy
but we still don't have nearly enough
and we are going to be beaten unless we
find a way to address the manpower issue
so in his in his issue paper then he
recommended that slaves be utilized as
Confederate soldiers and that consistent
with historical use of slaves in warfare
that slaves who fought would at the end
of the war together with their families
be freed so this is a lot to swallow for
a lot of people this was basically
saying use black as Confederate soldiers
and by the way you should in Ansip ate a
large number of them now he first of all
got about 13 of his own generals within
his when his large division to sign off
on this they thought they thought it was
a pretty good idea at least they weren't
going to disagree with the boss so he
went in with this paper signed by
himself and 13 others presented it to
Joseph Johnston who was the commander in
the Tennessee Georgia area at the time
this was before the Atlanta Campaign
started our early 64 and he presented
this proposal and he argued for it and
Johnston had called a general meeting in
response to a request from Clayburn and
so Johnston had all of his other
division commanders and deputy
commanders and just a whole slew of
military leaders in the quote Western
theater attending this meeting and
Johnston remains silent after the
presentation was made and one person
spoke up in support of clay burns
proposal and that was his former law
partner out of Arkansas General Hindman
and Hinman actually himself had
an anonymous letter to a newspaper month
or two before pushing for the same idea
but other than that everybody else
opposed they not only opposed it they
violently opposed it and they said among
other things and this came up again and
again on the question of using blacks as
soldiers they said look we fought this
war we are fighting this war over the
issue of slavery our contention is that
slaves are not capable of being soldiers
if we admit that they are soldiers or if
they are successful of being soldiers we
undermine the whole argument that
supports the rationale for slavery so we
cannot do this and Johnston sat on the
proposal Kleber and have one of them to
send it to Richmond one of the other
generals of the meeting who violently
opposed it snuck a copy to President
Davis directly the president Davis and
Davis saw and exploded and so Davis
along with his Secretary of War John
Seddon and his chief military adviser
Braxton Bragg who had been promoted
under the double Peter Principle
to Davis's to Davis's military advisor
at that point the three of them started
using words like treason take names keep
a list I watched these men to death Dada
and Davis finally had the Secretary of
War send the word back to Johnston
destroy all copies of the proposal and
no one shall ever discuss this again and
he almost succeeded in destroying the
records because the only copy that ever
appeared was found twenty years later
when Confederate records were being
assembled to produce the official
records of the war rebellion and there
it was and so that's in the official
records if you choose to read clay burns
very thoughtful and thought-provoking
proposal which at that time got nowhere
one clear effect that had is it stopped
his career advancement because over the
next ten months
before he was killed in general hoods
suicidal attack at Franklin Tennessee in
November of that year there were three
times that corps commander positions
became open in in that army the army of
Tennessee and and that meant also that
there were three possibilities to be
promoted from two stars to three stars
clay clay burns got nothing even though
he has a brilliant record in the war so
his his idea was rejected now ironically
about the same time that he was killed
all of a sudden jefferson davis and
robert e lee come around because they're
at the top of the pyramid and they see
what's going on on a nationwide basis
which is that 1863 was bad but 1864 is
even worse from a confederate manpower
perspective because other tremendous
losses the confederacy suffered in
grant's Overland campaign in Virginia
although they suffered numerically less
than granted the percentage of
casualties was higher and they were
irreplaceable and at the same time
Sherman that had a very successful
campaign in Georgia and by this time had
captured Atlanta Georgia
so confederates continued to take heavy
casualties their manpower situation was
now something that could not be ignored
so Davis and Lee then began an effort to
convince the Confederate Congress that
they should use of black soldiers
specifically free slaves and use them as
soldiers and then emancipate them and
maybe their families as well so November
December of 1864 and then long the early
1865 they continued to make this push
but if you want evidence about what the
Confederacy was all about what you have
to do is look at the politicians
statements the congressmen statements
the Senators
statements the public statements and the
press the southern press and again we
have this rejection of the concept
because it's inconsistent with what we
are fighting for and if we did this it
would just undercut our whole rationale
for slavery so because of the strong
opposition the proposal got nowhere
until finally about March the 8th or 9th
of of 1865 one month before Appomattox
the Confederate Senate by 9 to 8 and the
Confederate House by a very narrow road
finally approved using some black slaves
as soldiers in the Confederate Army but
there were a couple caches there
released three captures one was the
master the master of the slave had to
agree
number two the state from which the
state came had to agree and number three
there was no Emancipation promised as
part of the deal so that is what passed
that is what passed and basically it
became something of fiasco there were
about 200 black corpsman taken out of
Richmond hospitals organized into two
companies and they were paraded and
drilled in Richmond fact they performed
the nine your arms they weren't given
any arms but they perform the manual at
arms and and they never played any role
in any fighting in the in the waning
days of the Confederacy as Richmond fell
and then Appomattox Courthouse followed
shortly thereafter so despite the fact
that it absolutely had to have more
manpower
in order to win the war the Confederacy
consistently rejected that approach
until the last desperate hour and by the
way the defenders of the laws cause will
always throw this out and say well you
know the Confederate Congress authorized
the use of slaves oh yeah they did they
did one month before the war was over
and and and they did it in such a manner
that nothing ever came of it now other
things the Confederacy
Civil War which give you an indication
of how important slavery was visa vie
winning the war prisoner Wars change
again we get back to manpower critical
needs to the south so they benefit
greatly the first half of the war
because the north engaged with them in
prisoner of war exchanges they were
essentially one-for-one now you might
have some some refined rules like one
one colonel equals ten privates and that
kind of thing but your sense we had one
for one trade-offs between the
Confederacy and the Union for the first
half of the war ah but then along comes
Emancipation Proclamation and northern
recruitment and training and use of
black soldiers beginning in mid 1863 so
what happened there
is that black soldiers who were on the
losing side were often shot down as they
tried to surrender and if they were
lucky enough to survive they were
treated as slaves as property as assets
and not as prisoners of war and the
South specifically Davis and Lee refused
to exchange them so grant and Lincoln
said well that's too bad then because
we're going to stop prisoner of war
exchanges and so the exchanges were
stopped until almost the end of the war
until David Lee changed their view but
for a critical excuse me a critical year
and a half of the war on the South
needed every man it could get they
refused to trade prisoners with the
north so Lee what if we it refused to
trade blacks and the north end
reciprocated by not trading at all now
you would have to say that it's pretty
clear that Lincoln and Grant weren't
acting solely out of out of
consideration for the captured blacks
let's be honest they also knew that the
fallout would be that the Confederacy
was no longer benefiting from these
prisoner Awards changes but I think it's
as a classic example of slavery
driving the issue and even though the
actions taken on slavery were
inconsistent with what the Confederates
needed to win the war and the final area
I'd point to is international diplomacy
suffice it to say that the South was
very reluctant to guarantee England in
particular and also France and the Pope
that they would they would end slavery
and make sure that the slate
international slave trade was completely
stopped and if you want some real good
insight into that there's a book that
came out probably about two years ago
called our man in Charleston our man in
Charleston by Christopher Dickey v IC ke
ke Y and the British consul in
Charleston South Carolina was there from
about 1854 to 1864 and obviously he was
white man and so the white aristocracy
made certain assumptions about his
political views obviously being
pro-slavery etc and so they were way too
frank with him for their own good so he
kept feeding all this information to
Britain and made it clear during the
civil war itself that don't trust them
they they are not going to back off of
slavery and and obviously Britain was
not going to intervene on the side of a
state that was actively promoting
slavery so once again they acted out
there they acted at their Perl okay
there was I have one other book to
mention to you and and and that
triggered one other issue so if I may
retreat for just a second and say that
one other piece of evidence about this
is contemporaneous evidence why see
session occurred was that as the first
seven states went out five of those
states appointed 51 delegates to go to
other slave states note not nor other
than slave states but they went to other
slave states to try to convince them to
leave the Union and to join the
Confederacy and I don't need to tell you
what the arguments were
because they were all the same arguments
I've already told you about all night
but what I wanted I do want to tell you
that if you want to look into that
there's a small book a few years old
called apostles of disunion
apostles of this union a very clever
title by charles do de w and it talks
about these missionaries for the
Southern cause talking to the other
states and every argument they made was
slavery related every argument they made
so that takes care of the three books
that I wanted to make sure that I that I
mentioned okay moving on did the South
have a chance to win the war the myth
says no the South never had a chance to
win the Civil War and I would make the
difference at the beginning of the war
southern leaders were pretty much
anonymous in thinking they would win
there was a great precedent called the
American Revolution in which the the
outgunned less powerful party won now in
the Revolution the colonists ended up
doing things very intelligently
Washington took two punches in the nose
before he realized he had to do this but
he avoided major conflicts and and and
acted very defensively and frustrated
the British and ultimately the British
population gave up on the war and in
addition the colonists played their
cards correctly internationally and got
the kind of European assistance that the
Confederacy did not get now at that
early stage of the war then you had
military experts for example that London
Times military correspondent you had
southern leaders almost unanimously
because of course one Confederate
soldier was the equivalent of three
northern soldiers and so there was a
great belief that the Confederacy would
win the war now there are some very
sound reasons for thinking that that was
likely to happen because after the
second batch of southern states seceded
you had 11 States
forming this massive land area about
two-thirds the size of Western Europe
which had to be conquered by the north
all the South needed was a tie or a
stalemate but the North needed an
affirmative victory and the South
however ended up not being satisfied
with a tie or stalemate whether it
didn't seem dramatic enough whether
Lee's personal convictions about what
was the right thing to do the South
under Lee in particular went on the
attack on the aggressive bow
strategically and tactically
strategically we have the Gettysburg and
Antietam campaigns in to the north and
again and again and I'll talk about a
few T's when I talk about Lee in a few
minutes but the South did not play its
cards well at all and there were all
kinds of reasons why to the state on the
defensive strategically and tactically
and it did not do so and and there's no
reasonably South could not have won the
war militarily on that basis alone huge
area difficult to conquer and especially
with the weapons developments that that
had occurred between the Mexican War and
the Civil War so I was saying that the
South could militarily have won the war
in addition is a whole separate line of
thought that I've developed over time
which I think has some validity to it
and that is that South an excellent
chance of winning the war politically
and this is not ex post facto rationale
in 1863 and 1864 the correspondence the
diaries of Confederate leaders indicate
they were looking forward to the
election of 1864 they recognized how
important that election was because
Abraham Lincoln was the steel backbone
of the Civil War his election had really
brought it about by bringing the slavery
issue to the fore and Lincoln was
the steel backbone of the press and the
Congress they went hither in bitter but
Lincoln was solid and Confederate
through wise this and so they were
looking forward to this and said if we
can defeat Lincoln in 1864 we'll get a
lot of what we want and especially as it
turned out because George McClellan was
running against them and George wanted
nothing to do with ending slavery
whatsoever and George was also willing
that's some kind of a truce of pause a
ceasefire to talk things over well I
think once that happened that's pretty
much the end of it but so how could how
could the election have gone in favor of
McClellan the first thing is that
superficially we've always heard the
election of 1864 was a landslide that it
was fifty five percent to forty five
percent and electoral votes or something
like two twelve to twenty one so it
sounds like McClellan had no prayer but
if you dig into the numbers that were
thought there were four million voters
four million voters and if less than one
percent is something like twenty nine
thousand of those voters had changed
their votes in selected northern states
McClellan wins by one electoral vote
there were a lot of close States and and
it would not have taken much of a shift
so we're talking less than one percent
voter ship would have given the election
to McClellan which I found a stamp I
find astounding in light of the fact
that in the ten weeks leading up to the
election all kinds of military
developments had gone in favor of the
Union you had the fall of Mobile Harbor
you had the fall of Atlanta you had Phil
shirt in cleaning out the Shenandoah
Valley and so there should have been no
reason to give up on the war no reason
to do anything other than support
Lincoln and let's bring this thing to an
end
based on what positive developments were
going on
but despite all that as I said the
election was very very close a lot
closer than is commonly understood so
that's enough enough of my opinions
about it was not it was not at all
inevitable that the North would win or
that the South would lose you have to
examine very deeply the possibilities of
southern victory and part of this ties
into robert e lee now we'll move into
Lee Lee was according to the legend one
of the greatest generals who ever lived
and as I said before he was made the
mini god of the myth of the lost cause
several years ago my late father-in-law
died after reading a whole slew books on
the Civil War came to the startling
conclusion that you know each one of
these authors had had something negative
to say about Lee but always apologized
for it now it was uncharacteristically
Lee did that out of character Lee did
did this other thing and and and the
authors were not all pointing to the
same thing they were pointing to a
variety of issues and so that point I
said to my father-in-law I said you know
I'm going to write a book on how robert
e lee lost the Civil War and that that
was my book number one I lived in
Virginia at the time I now live in
Pennsylvania
and anyway so I have to I have some
criticisms of leaves generalship first
of all Lee was a Virginian first and
they Confederate second no big surprise
there before the Civil War a lot of
people identified themselves with their
states and no one ever said the United
States is a or said the United States
are but in the case of Virginians and
then Glee in particular he was he was
really into almost a religious faith in
his state wherever Virginia went he was
going to go and and actually when he
declined command of all federal armies
at the beginning of the war he said I
will lift my sword only in defense of
not the Confederacy the Old Dominion and
and so from the beginning he was very
open aboveboard
and people had to realize this guy's
interested in Virginia and maybe in not
much else and that is the way it played
out my favorite example of this is that
in 1862 Lee on his own without approval
from anybody in Richmond shortly after
second Manassas decided to cross the
Potomac and invade Pennsylvania now he
got bogged down in Maryland and what's
known as the Maryland or the Antietam
campaign and when he wrote to Davis he
said by the way we're crossing the
Potomac going enemy territory I think
it's a long shot but it's worth it and
gave him some political advice I think
this will have a great impact on Europe
if we can have a big victory Lee said in
the letters the Davis by the way since I
am leaving
Richmond uncovered by taking his whole
army into enemy territory said I
recommend that you bring Braxton Bragg
and his troops in from Tennessee to
protect Richmond at the time that Lee
made his recommendation Braxton Bragg in
East Tennessee was outnumbered
three-to-one by Union opponents and and
so it would lead me to
and not just that but I will generally
conclude that Lee either did not know or
do not care what was going on in any
theater outside of his own precious
Virginia theater the only time that
reinforcements went from Lee's army
elsewhere was when Longstreet was
finally allowed to go down to
Chickamauga lead the laid that movement
by three weeks during those three weeks
Union soldiers captured Knoxville
Tennessee blocking the easy and simple
route to get down to the Chattanooga
area and that forced Longstreet who
started through weeks late to take an
eight to ten day trip using eight to ten
small railroads to get through the
Carolinas and Georgia to get to the
Chickamauga battlefield I've took them
all the battlefield Longstreet showed up
in the middle of a two-day battle had
roughly one-half of his troops had none
of his artillery had none of us horses
and mules so he went in with one arm
tied behind his back now due to due to
some federal one competence and some
good luck for the Confederates
Longstreet was in a strong position to
pretty much destroy Rosecrans his army
but you may recall that George Thomas
became known as the rock of Chickamauga
by defending the high ground horseshoe
Ridge Snodgrass Hills got a couple names
for the whole afternoon and into the
evening before he made an orderly
retreat to join the rest of Rosecrans
fleeing army back in Chattanooga and I'm
and I think the outcome could have been
quite different had Longstreet had his
complete force including all of his
artillery insofar as trying to blast
Thomas off the high ground at
Chickamauga but it gets worse within two
days after Longstreet was finally Lee
was ordered by Davis
very unusual Lee was ordered by David to
send Longstreet down two days at the
Longstreet started moving Lee wrote to
Davidson said among many other things he
said
I've got an idea about Longstreet after
he gets down there and he fights the
major battle that is obviously in the
offing what should be done with
Longstreet he should be moved from the
Chattanooga area up to northeastern
Tennessee to Knoxville where he can
chase out the Union forces that are
there and then this is Lee and then he
can come quickly back to my army the
only army that really counted the army
in Northern Virginia and this this may
sound like a almost like a joke funny
little proposal on the side whatever but
this had fatal consequences because what
happened is after the Battle of
Chickamauga the Confederates on scene
got into a huge finger-pointing contest
with basically Bragg pointing the finger
at all the subordinates and all his
subordinates pointing the finger at
Bragg as to who let Rosecrans army
escape at Chickamauga why are they
askance back in Chattanooga and so they
were blaming each other and Davis went
personally down to try to settle the
dispute and he settled it in typical
Davis Ian fashion in which Davis you
have to recall either loved or hated you
and Bragg was one of his buddies so in
what must have been one of the most
intriguing conferences of the war Bragg
subordinates sat there in the presence
of Bragg and all recommended the Bragg
be removed from command o subordinates
telling the the President to remove this
commander and what happens Davis
basically sustained Bragg in his
position and removed most of the
subordinates now one little problem was
that Longstreet was such a subordinate
on loan and there's little doubt that
Longstreet went out to that theater with
the idea of you know grag screws up
maybe I can get that command and have my
own independent command and not just be
working for Bobby Lee and and so after
Chickamauga Longstreet real
and and and what Davis did Longstreet
realized well there goes that plan and
then on the other hand Bragg knew what
Longstreet had tried to do that he had
stirred up this dissent among the among
the subordinates and it didn't need much
stirring up but but Longstreet did stir
it up so Davis then thinks he you know I
had this wonderful suggestion from
robert e lee about what to do and that
is to send Longstreet off to off to
Knoxville and and leave Bragg
with the rest of his army in the
Chattanooga area so he suggests that to
both Bragg and the Longstreet so for
separate reasons they both agree so
Longstreet is sent away with 15,000
troops up to Knoxville this is when the
Confederates semi encircled Chattanooga
and the Union realized the critical
importance of Chattanooga as a gateway
to Atlanta and also a defensive area
protecting against the Confederate
invasion into the heart of the northern
Midland into the Midwest and so the
Union at the same time number one they
brought in Grant and said we want you to
take care of this we want you to save
the army that's trapped there get rid of
the Confederate through in that area and
they sent around two cores two entire
cores 20,000 troops one by rail from the
Virginia theater through the Midwest all
the way down to Alabama and then into
into Chattanooga
in addition Sherman was marched from the
Mississippi valleys always crossed the
length of Tennessee to get in the fray
as well so what happens in a numbers
basis is that while the Union is
building its forces in Chattanooga to 75
to 80 thousand troops Lee's wonderful
suggestion has resulted in the
Confederates going from 50,000 to 35,000
so Confederates were spread thin they
had no reserve and so when you had the
miracle breakthrough at Missionary Ridge
Confederates had no reserve their line
starts being
up from the middle and the entire army
flees back into Georgia setting the
stage for Sherman's Atlanta campaign of
the next year so this is this is a good
example of the kinds of impacts that Lee
had on other theaters other than other
than the Virginia theater so that's
number one Virginian first and a
confederate second the other the other
major problem with Lee is given
everything given all the relevant
circumstances he was way way too
aggressive way too offensive he thought
as though he as though he were a union
general with unlimited resources and the
strategic necessity to go on the attack
Isaac as claimed before my theory is
that the South only needed the tie or
stalemate and they needed simply to make
it very difficult for the Union to
capture southern armies to capture
southern territory and to repel the
Union attacks at least to the extent of
making it so bloody that the northern
morale would decline northern people
would give up on the war and believe me
that came very close to happening in in
the middle of 1864 but instead of doing
that Lee for whatever reasons went on
the strategic offensive the Antietam
campaign and the Gettysburg Campaign
between the two of those he lost about
75 took about 75,000 casualties and in
addition within Virginia alone
tactically seven days battle the first
major battle if the Lee took command of
his army was a one-week series of
attacks by Lee on McClellan's army and
Lee did achieve a strategic success by
driving McClellan away from Richmond
fact McClellan started fleeing the
instantly sort of attacking and the
point here though is that Lee had a tree
to strategic goal of
moving McClellan getting McClellan's
army and retreat away from Richmond the
end of one day and by the end of two
days Lee knew from reports from Jeb
Stewart that this was the case but he
kept attacking for the rest of the week
and so in that campaign Lee took 20,000
casualties to McClellan 16,000 and
McClellan casualties were soft they
included a lot of missing leaves
calories were hard casualties killed and
wounded 20,000 pretty much all killed
and wounded that was not a good start
there was not an auspicious beginning
because the South could not afford to
fight the war in that way now one you
may not have heard of is the back end of
the Battle of Chancellorsville Lee was
on the offensive against fortified Union
positions and took very heavy losses
there and then the one that you
definitely know about is Gettysburg
we're on days two and three Lee
essentially did nothing but assault
strong federal positions on high ground
against Longstreet's advice and and and
took just a severe severe beating so
again and again again and again during
the war the record is replete with
strategic and tactical aggressive
behavior by Lee which was inappropriate
for the South because of the fact that
the North had the burden winning the war
and the South so badly outnumbered could
not afford to squander its manpower in
addition one other factor is this the
weaponry had changed significantly since
the Mexican War and so during the course
of the Civil War you're talking about
widespread use of rifles instead of
muskets put about rifled artillery
probably about breech loaders and set of
muzzle loaders use of the minie ball
form of bullet if you will which was
much more accurate and as we're
progressing even further the use of
repeaters what did all these things do
they move the power from the offensive
ones that have been in the Mexican War
to the defensive
defense had the power in the Civil War
you did not want to attack unless you
had to Lee did not have to but he did
and some demonstration of my point is
that about 80 percent of the battles of
the Civil War in about 80 percent the
tactical winner was the defender just
could not be budged from where the
defender was so you really did not want
to attack unless you had to and Lee
attacked again and again so those are
some of my reasons for some of my
reasons for Lee not being the great
general that we heard of now one second
on Longstreet he's blamed for Gettysburg
scapegoat here's the bottom line on that
on Lee's birthday there big celebrations
they started the year after he died
so 1871 1872 on Lee's birthday famous
speeches were given on the first one by
Jubilee the second one by William Nelson
Pendleton and they created the story out
of whole cloth and they said that Lee
had ordered Longstreet to attack the
enemy at dawn on day two of the three
day Gettysburg battle suffice it to say
total I had nothing to support it that's
been well proven over time although it
took about a hundred years for people to
seriously look into it and come to the
conclusion that that was not so at all
and so what we think now is that Lee
ordered Longstreet to attack ten or
eleven o'clock in the morning that he
gave Longstreet until noon because
Longstreet stolen troops coming up the
road which tells you that it's unlikely
that Lee would have ordered an attack at
dawn especially since Lee only sent out
a scouting parties of dawn so the whole
thing was a lie but it was to tour the
reputation of James Longstreet and to
take Lee off the hook now Lee committed
a slew of errors at Gettysburg the
highlights being number one on at the
end of day one when Union armies were
retreat through the town of Gettysburg
back toward the high ground total
disarray Lee came on scene gave the
worst order of the civil war to General
Richard you'll in which he told that
second corps commander he said take the
high ground if practicable if
practicable now a Jackson been alive it
died two months before and had commanded
that Corps every effort would have been
made to capture it there's an ongoing
debate about whether if the Confederates
had done it would they or would they not
have captured the high ground the only
thing I'll say is that that was the best
chance that Lee had to capture the high
ground the entire time he was a
Gettysburg and he basically did not take
it he gave a week general a week order
and so nothing nothing came of it okay
so that's that's the Longstreet story in
a nutshell there's oh and also I need to
point out that that Lee then on days two
and three of Gettysburg launched
continuous a series of attacks on the
high ground and he never did so at the
same time there was never a
contemporaneous attack on all the Union
forces what he did was he had Longstreet
an attack on the south and within an
hour after that attack Peters out
finally 24 hours late Richard Jewell
attacks on the north and not attack
fevers out the next day Pickett goes up
the middle so you have South North
middle and essentially oversimplified
but two-thirds of Lee's army watched the
other one-third carrying out these
attacks it was an abominable campaign
and military historians are in pretty
much unanimous agreement about it was
Lee's worst and it was devastatingly bad
okay that moves us on to ulysses grant
grant was called a butcher and it was
said that he only won through brute
force we don't have time to go through
his brilliant Vicksburg campaign in
which he was outnumbered in the theater
and enemy territory won five battles in
18 days because
he didn't just use brute force he used
deception he used speed he used
concentration of force he was
outnumbered in the theater until he
began the siege of Vicksburg when he won
these five battles yet he died by
fooling the enemy each of the five
battles grant had more than the enemy
did because the enemy didn't know where
it was they didn't know where they
should be so it was an absolutely
brilliant campaign and again again grant
grant has a record during the war he
captured Fort Henry and Donaldson at in
February 1862 first major Union victory
he captured Vicksburg arguably the most
important campaign of the Civil War he
then was brought in saved Chattanooga
within a month rescued a Union Army
trapped there was so well regarded as a
result of all this that he was promoted
to general and chief and three stars and
ended up and asked to win the war which
he did within 11 months so I think the
record is pretty clear about grant
success now let me deal one minute with
the casualty statistics which I have
studied to a to it fairly well and I've
got some here doo-doo-doo-doo okay these
are these are grants casualties and I
don't know if we have a a total know
okay we do up the top of the right hand
side here's the story on casualties
we're comparing grant and Lee not just
against each other but against all their
foes in the course of the war as my
favorite synopsis grant commanded five
armies and three theatres was a winner
everywhere that he went
and did all that he did including
capturing three enemy armies at a cost
of one hundred and fifty four thousand
calories while he imposed on an eighty
one thousand casualties on the enemy
casualties are killed wounded missing
and captured not just kill killed
wounded Michigan captured granted all
that he did in three theaters for the
toll
one hundred and fifty four thousand
casualties
li on the other hand commanded one army
in one theater which he lost and did so
at the cost of two hundred and nine
thousand casualties fifty-five thousand
casualties more than grant so you can
understand with on based on that
analysis anyway where I really have to
say we've been sold something of a bill
of goods about how greatly was and about
how bad grant was and quite frankly the
majority of civil war historians are now
believed that grant was the greatest
general of the Civil War even if the
general public is not that's where the
real damage has occurred is the general
public has been saturated with this
story for 150 years plus and has bought
into a lot of it so I regard the myth of
the Lost Cause as the most successful
propaganda campaign in American history
and so I leave you to be the final
judges on that and thank you for
listening to my biased opinions
thank you thank you okay
there are microphones in each aisle and
we have just 15 minutes to deal with any
questions anyone would like to ask and
we will stop at 8:45 sharp so you can
get out of here and go home if you like
does anybody have any questions sir
there's a mic back there's much typing
yeah you can go back back to the mic go
ahead how far along did efforts come for
the north to purchase the freedom of the
slaves to stop the civil war from
happening and if if they were considered
what was the total cost of that compared
to the cost of the Civil War
eventually okay that's that's a real
good question I assume everyone heard it
since he has a mic okay Abraham Lincoln
explored the purchase of slaves a
compensated emancipation is the term
generally generally used and and Lincoln
at first when he explored this was
willing to consider migrating of sending
those slaves to Africa or to settlements
in Central America or the Caribbean but
Lincoln explored the concept of buying
the freedom of slaves and he had done
the kind of calculation that you talked
about and he used Delaware which had a
very small number of slaves no more than
two thousand has a good example and so
he had some calculations that for the
cost of one day of war you could free a
thousand slaves and go on from there but
so he tried to sell this to the border
states these are one still members of
the Union they had not gone out and they
just would not go along with it he held
meetings with Delaware held meetings for
the four border state representatives
and no one bought into it no one at all
so even even in the border states there
was such a firm belief in slavery that
they were not willing to consider
selling their slaves in order to avoid
the war
which again tells us something about
maybe the slavery thing was not just
economics but it was economics plus
politics plus social uh a lot of those
things went hand in glove yes sir thank
you very much for your presentation I
was wondering whether you consider the a
lot of it is the Shelby Foote Shelby
Foote was a dyed-in-the-wool southerner
it was very entertaining commenter in
the Ken Burns series on the Civil War
and I would say don't read his early
read about 20 other civil war books
before you go to his told you now is
simply because this trilogy doesn't have
any dates doesn't have any footnotes and
it's very readable because foot was a
novelist and he did a lot of research
and he put his heart into it and he
tells a great story I found it very
useful because I had read 30 books on
the Civil War at least and I just had
all these pieces and I felt that Shelby
put it all together
he very he would simply say here's what
was happening in Virginia and it
meanwhile down in Mississippi and so he
sort of made it possible for me anyway
to be able to visualize the war as a
total entity and I found it very useful
in that regard it's very colorful some
people who might not just want to read
historians books with lots of footnotes
and everything might find his colorful
approach to be good but I do warn I
would I would say I wouldn't do that
until you familiar salt familiarize
yourself with a lot of other books and
for God's sake do not use use it as a
case book I've made that mistake and use
it as a as a course book in the college
course and it was just way too beyond
the students at particularly because it
had no source citations and because it
had no dates it was just and then and
meanwhile etc etc so but it's it reads
beautifully and it has its place
but Shelby Shelby does have a lot of the
tendencies of the supporters of the myth
of the lost cause you're welcome yes sir
according to Gary Gallagher at
University of Virginia
Craig discerning of black troops well
let's say black support he said that
Lee went into the Gettysburg Campaign I
believe with 77 thousand troops but also
they took with them 10 about 10,000
slaves that not only were personal
servants in laundry they also were
Teamsters that they were cooked and they
may not have been firing artillery but
they may have been driving the horses on
the thing is this a fair assumption I
think that's a fair assumption I don't
know about the number of 10,000 and
certainly as possible because when Lee
invaded Pennsylvania he needed a lot of
transportation need a lot of Teamsters
he needed a lot of people to do a lot of
grunge work loading all of the the
grains that were taken out of the state
I mean the Cumberland Valley was
stripped it was a huge it was a huge
market basket for Lee and maybe the best
thing that came out of the Gettysburg
Campaign was the success in moving
cattle and horses and mules and huge
quantities of materials back and having
having a black slaves to do it with free
up white soldiers but what that doesn't
get around is the fact these people were
slaves they were slaves they were not
subject to the Uniform Code of Military
Justice they did not get promotions they
did not get any kind of military pay
they were assets they were slaves and
they they really got no respect but they
were resources I think I mentioned them
earlier they were used to build
fortifications and that kind of thing
so there were subsidiary jobs something
less than a full soldier that they were
allowed to do and I think that makes it
very difficult to study that issue of
for slaves used to not and that's why
you have to get into well let's see what
Congress officially authorized they do
not authorize slaves to be used sir yeah
I thank you the book was wonderful but I
also something that you touched on in
the book and you didn't have as much
time for tonight though touched on the
idea of General Sherman and I've read
two biographies of them Furious patriot
and American general by David Eisenhower
and I just wanted to put as a question
to you do you think he's unfairly
treated as a casualty of the myth and
that he is actually extremely effective
general but he gets swept up in this
hatred in the myth and a reason to
sympathize with the sound correct you're
right I didn't reach that point that
sort of my last point had to do with the
allegations that the North won only by
total war and the allegation is
primarily that Sherman in Georgia and
the Carolinas and that Sheridan in the
Shenandoah Valley of the classic
examples of the North using total war
and when I say is excuse me there's a
difference between total war and hard
war total war is Genghis Khan tamerlane
the 30 Years War in Germany what's the
Russians the Germans and the Japanese
did in World Wars 1 and 2 that is you go
in and you have mass rapes & nass
murders of civilians intentional
deliberate of destruction of civilian
population because total to me means
unfettered easy you use every weapon at
your disposal and you just obliterate
the enemy what the North did to
ultimately when the war was exercised
hardiwar hard war and that term is used
a lot too and I think it's much more
accurate to describe what happened but
the North did yeah they went in they did
a lot of damage they burn barns that
burn crops that killed animals they
basically imposed severe critical
economic damage on the south but that's
not total war that's on total war and of
course books continue to be written
what Sherman did to us and things like
that and and basically has it well
Sherman gave you break because he didn't
go around
killing people I mean very few deaths
involved in in his March uh and and the
same thing is true of Sheridan so there
were sprinklings of minor skirmishes but
basically what we're talking about is go
in and destroy the enemy infrastructure
and that's called hard war and the
morale the South plummeted as a result
of what Sherman was doing and many of
the tens of thousands of deserters from
Lee's Army for people who in good faith
went home because they felt a greater
responsibility to the their wives and
children than they did to what was left
of the Confederate cause in 1864 and
1865 thank you sir
I want to follow up in a way I think the
morale issue is something germane
I mean you've depicted very well I think
the the reasons for the the myth was all
very reasonable but when you get into
this notion of morale and mindset and
the the other factors that that did
exist in the South that helped propagate
the myths I mean they lost they were
ravaged not just by the war between
struction there was this endemic poverty
there was a you know a romantic ideal to
begin with that existed there and then
the war really deflated that so I think
yes it's reasonable to look at the data
and say yeah this is this missus bogus
but it it that doesn't mean that it's
easily dealt with
you know inter especially in them in the
minds of the southern people who you
know so strongly hold on to it and I so
you didn't get into that issue of the
the mindset that that helps propagate
the myth and I'm wondering if you have
any comment on that okay well I think
that when you when you look at the minds
behind the succession resolutions the
Confederate Constitution the outreach to
other states of etcetera that were
occurring at that time which we can put
our we can put our fingers on and say it
was these were all about slavery now if
you back off and say but what about the
people and their morale then you get
into an almost insoluble dilemma about
individual soldiers fought for different
reasons individual people felt different
ways about the war and so it's very hard
to it's very hard to pin that down but I
really think that the kinds of evidence
that I'm looking at it's not just data
these are the words that the
participants used and every and every
one says nothing but slavery now you
mentioned in passing reconstruction and
that's a whole another book and a whole
another field but basically my take on
reconstruction very subjective just like
everything else I've been saying is that
is that reconstruction would not have
been so bad if the southerners had done
had responded appropriately to what the
war was about and that is in good faith
ended slavery and truly ended slavery
and slave related practices and provided
blacks with the right to participate in
politics to to vote and to have
representatives in government which was
only allowed for a short time while the
North was there to enforce it and so the
stories about all the economical ravages
on the south there wasn't much left to
ravage and and what the South was really
concerned about what the southerners as
as a rule were concerned about that
blacks were being given rights and this
was not something that they could
tolerate and so they literally stopped
it your Jim Crow laws and and you did
not have legitimate black rights until
at least the mid nineteen
60s and and so so I think that there are
a lot of aspects of the myth that carry
over into what was reconstruction all
about and I'm not an expert in
reconstruction but there are those that
are but I would just again I would
approach the traditional view of
reconstruction with great deal of
skepticism yes sir last question should
we have been executed as a traitor
and if he had what effect would that
have had on the myth of the lost cause
okay executing Lee's trader would have
been totally inconsistent with what
Lincoln wanted to do and would have
served no real purpose it would have
served no real purpose and it might very
well have aggravated the south so that
the myth would even be worse than it is
so it would be an extreme step but
Lincoln will not have wanted to do that
okay thank you very much again ladies